okay okay let us know in the comments if
you think that lava lamps are cultural
appropriation cut as always good effort
some positive news the company's
expanding medical coverage so you should
all have insurance by the end of the
quarter what does that mean really
Hannah okay dr. Ryan explain to me
medical insurance medical insurance is
it's insurance that you need nice for
Hannah can you not the bully Ryan he
can't help that he's the head of the
group now these policies are very
specific so I want you to make sure you
read every word of these packets
including the fine print and Braille
pass
[Music]
you're here early
yeah I didn't go to sleep yet my doctor
he started me on 50 milligrams of IV
it's like a neuro on speed I've read
this book twice I wrote a screenplay and
I organized my barbecue like are you
sure that our insurance covers
psychiatric care
Cleo isn't a psychic she's legit my
insurance car is actually like a Six
Flags VIP pass for drugs you don't have
to pay for your vyvanse I just show the
farms with my car and they give me
whatever I want
I've never taken a thing off sup geezers
oh whoa
Jenna what happened to your face
preventive Botox this is just the
initial swelling doctor said I'll go
down in like three weeks where did you
go pop up in the back of em are you sure
you went to a real doctor yes Nate I'm
not an idiot
our insurance covered it can you believe
it enough to pay a dime yes I don't
think that our insurance covers Botox
did you not read page 11 of the packet I
don't know it seems wrong
exactly it's insurance how's it going
down there Jesus Jordan are you okay if
by okay you mean tall then I am better
than okay by four inches exactly took a
lot of stretching and implants but I
will be good to go in about 37 rehab
visits where the extra bones come from
my dad donated them what happened to him
he's just shorter now Jordan is a
pre-existing condition Hayes 36 read the
packet Nate you guys all read that
big-ass packet I can't even get you to
read my emails that's because they offer
us nothing
I found an experimental doctor that
gives humans reptile features there in
the wall guys allow you the sun's heat
now or something
oh yeah I know they're rats in the walls
because I put them there my sink guys
are actually purely cosmetic okay seems
clear to me that you are all cheating
the system in various ways it's at least
good to know that we have full coverage
full coverage
no we're just lucky that all our
procedures are unnecessary sir hey buddy
I just got word that your insurance
company does not cover emergency
appendectomy so I'm gonna have to put
this bag of poison back inside of it but
it's already oh I don't make the rules
sir
didn't your employer provide you with an
information package is busy reading
emails so Betty emails dice not to do
this
[Music]
you